if ever there was a film that was
wrongly compared to another film it's
warm bodies to Twilight nothing like
each other at all warm bodies is
directed by Jonathan Levine and he made
the fantastic fifty-fifty so I was
really interested in this movie purely
because of his involvement a lot of
people were like it's it's by Summit
Entertainment the same people who made
Twilight it's another paranormal like
romance this is gonna be stupid no this
world essentially the zombie apocalypse
has already happened and all these
zombies are wandering around and they're
eating people and everything there are
still some humans who are trying to face
off against these zombies and then there
are these things called Boney's these
giant skeletons that basically are what
happens to the zombies eventually the
zombies eventually decay to the point
where they are just these evil skeletons
that want to do absolutely nothing but
eat the main character of this movie
played by Nicholas Hoult who you may
remember as the little guy from about a
boy or as beast from x-men first class
this guy has this thing where this human
side to him is starting to come back
he's tearing himself talking in his head
he wants to be different he doesn't want
to eat people but he just he kind of
does and you hear his narration as the
movie progresses and once he meets this
girl this human chick who's like this
complete hardcore chick with a gun
she's blasting away at zombies he
immediately falls in love with this girl
now how in the rule is he going to
convince her that he wants to be
different even though he's still a
zombie this movie could have been awful
it could have been another Twilight but
gratefully this movie understands the
comedy behind a situation like this it
is so funny so likable so clever and
completely endearing and it actually
gets pretty dramatic in a lot of good
ways and I'm gonna tell you that warm
bodies is the first movie that's come
out so far this year that I would
literally just say go see it I had a lot
of fun with this movie and one of the
biggest reasons is the film takes itself
the way it should it understands the
funny situation that these two
characters are in it understands the
humor behind it and because it
understands that it gets you into these
characters it makes you like these
characters a lot and as the film
progresses and it gets a little bit more
serious you are actually involved with
these people and you care about them and
you want to see stuff work out and the
best way for these people and it makes
two more interested in the movie it's
also very funny extremely clever and
well written and very well acted by
Nicholas Hoult he was fantastic as this
leads on be our he was so good in this
movie you really cared about him he got
a lot of laughs especially in the first
half of this movie where he's trying to
get this coal to notice him some really
funny stuff
I was really happy with this movie I was
just seeing they're like wow yes this is
like a really cool interesting romance
but it's also a fun movie for guys to
see as well it's not just some girly
romance don't think that at all this is
a very funny movie and it pushes the
boundaries of pg-13 a little bit the
asset cuts away from the more bloody
stuff but I actually wasn't sure if it
was pg-13 or R when the movie was over
Teresa Palmer plays this girl and I
thought she did a really good job in the
movie too I really liked the chemistry
between these two leads they worked well
together and they really played off each
other comedic Lee Anne doc I said as the
film progresses it gets a little bit
more serious a little bit more intense
some action involved really well handled
- and Jonathan Levine as a director is
interesting because with fifty-fifty he
took a subject that was very serious
that of cancer and he was able to find
the humor in it by that great script who
was written by the man who actually had
cancer himself warm bodies although a
complete departure from the plot of
fifty-fifty has a very similar way of
going about telling its story it takes
something that may be a little familiar
you may think zombie movie okay scary
horror romance in there from Twilight
you know you may think those things
immediately but he takes it in such a
different direction with this comedic
twist to it 50/50 and warm bodies proves
to me that Jonathan Levine really knows
how to do those genre-bending twisty
movies and I gotta say I definitely
recommend seeing warm bodies I had very
few problems with the movie even though
we didn't have a lot of time on screen
John Malkovich was also pretty good in
the film I'm definitely gonna recommend
this movie to you I'm gonna give warm
bodies and a - thanks a lot for watching
guys and as always if you like this then
you can click right here and get stuck
my eyes
[Music]